everyone I'm Walter Brennan and this is
top five here we countdown the best and
worst performances of our most beloved
actors we're doing the worst of Tom
Hanks today folks god help me Tom Hanks
has no bad performances there I said the
guy is always good even if the movie is
not great
he's always good he's even great in the
music video for the Carly Rae Jepsen
song I really like you that's right he
makes a video that features Justin
Bieber bearable I had to choose five
though that's the job
once again please keep in mind none of
these are bad they're just not as great
when compared to his best performances
and that's the only way I can
rationalize this list let's do this
number five Stephen Gould in punch line
there was a trend in the 80s when Hanks
was playing these jerks he's not bad as
this character type but he's so
charismatic that you always want to like
him for that reason it's difficult to
buy into him and roles like this Sally
Field plays a housewife and mother who
has always wanted to be a stand-up
comedian I want to be a comedian when
she seeks advice from Medical School
flunk out Stephen who happens to kill it
every night on stage they form an
unlikely bond that is both comedic and
heartbreaking Hanks plays the classic
smarmy screw-up in this movie he does
the best with the material given to him
but this script isn't very good I'm
guessing that maybe a decent amount was
cut out of the film too because big
events and character turns happen
throughout the movie for no reason the
motivations don't make sense
a love triangle develops between Hanks
field and John Goodman who plays fields
husband the Hanks field relationship was
really out of left field and while Hanks
tries to make those scenes work they
just aren't earned the thing that really
got me was hey that's DJ Tanner
[Music]
Hank's is pretty funny at a few moments
in the movie but all in all punchline
dragged him down a bit we all know he's
chosen much better roles and movies
number four Rick Gasko in bachelor party
I'm not a fan of these types of movies
and while Hanks fit the bill for this
kind of role in 1984 that's also the
same year that splash came out so I
think this may have been one of the last
times that he just played a delinquent
with no depth Rick is finally engaged to
his longtime girlfriend Debbie so his
friends decide to throw him one last big
party before he says I do the bachelor
party that ensues is anything but a
small send-off for Rick single status
prostitutes dead donkeys drugs and
alcohol make for a night to remember or
forget Hanks can be his usual charming
self in this movie and he maybe laughs a
few times
[Music]
there are also a few jokes that don't
land Debbie and bond James Bond one of
the only knocks I'll say against him is
that he can be a little over the top
hang see at a couple points
[Music]
bachelor party was right before people
started to take him seriously good thing
he left these types of roles behind
number three Sherman McCoy in the
bonfire of the vanities I can without a
doubt say that this is the worst movie
that features both Tom Hanks and Geraldo
Rivera adapted from the Tom Wolfe novel
Wall Street executive Sherman McCoy is
in the middle of a night out with his
greedy mistress Maria wherein she runs
over a black high school student and
drives off without going to the police
reporter Peter fallow discovers the
scandalous story and riles up New York
with his coverage of the case which soon
goes to trial Hanks plays another jerk
in this movie but this time a rich one
he seems a bit miscast in the film that
features some other big stars including
Bruce Willis Morgan Freeman and Melanie
Griffith it's the same problem I
mentioned earlier we all want to like
Tom Hanks but there's very little reason
to in this film because his character is
pretty sleazy for a lot of it the movie
is trying to say something profound
about race relations and the influence
of politics and the media but it just
comes off as preachy at a few points
just about everyone in the film is a
miserable human being there's really no
one that we're supposed to like except
maybe Morgan Freeman as the judge the
film was also shot in a very unique
manner lots of low angles split focuses
and other strange visuals cap off a film
that was peculiar from the start maybe
go check out the book but skip the film
number 2 Ray Peterson in the burbs this
movie isn't the worst thing in the world
although Hanks his usual spot on comedy
and personality don't find the right
outlet in this one suburbanite ray
Peterson's week off turns into a scary
wacky romp when his new neighbors give
the rest of the neighborhood reason for
concern they're never seen and strange
noises are heard coming from the house
in addition to graves dug in the
backyard is Ray just being paranoid or
is there something more sinister afoot
we all know the Hanks geo it's very
distinct there's a lot of it in this
movie
[Music]
we're the loonatics he's both
over-the-top and also looks pretty bored
I can't blame him though there's not
much for him to sink his teeth into here
he's just uncharacteristically bland and
doesn't have much to work with in terms
of characters to bounce off of script or
comedy the burbs isn't great and left
Hanks with a boring role Joe Dante has
directed much better movies to watch
those and the number one worst Tom Hanks
performance is Lawrence Watley born the
third in volunteers by have you seen
Thomas Henson volunteer why doesn't the
phone repays a rich man who and who he
joins the Peace Corps but of course he
fetches son Riley or even known to be a
bad man quite the tale after being
threatened by debt collectors rich
playboy Lawrence Bourne Stow's away on a
plane of peace corps volunteers set for
Thailand once they arrive the crew is
tasked with building a bridge the group
begins work but soon discover the CIA
communists and a drug lord have a vested
interest in the bridges construction
this is just a comedic performance that
doesn't work all that well for Hanks
he's playing yet another redeemable jerk
but this time with a rich guy accent
you're a douche bag you can't do this to
me I'm very rich right even through this
character a little bit of why we all
love Hank's still peeks out John for
what I'm about to do who you should be
ashamed
I'd like to go home please please can I
go home please just John Candy in the
future mrs. Hanks Rita Wilson also
appears in this film John Candy is
always enjoyable but this film is just a
basic story with a different setting
nothing to write home about and Hanks
his performance is subpar for his
outstanding career there I did now go
watch his good movies but you're
basically all I want to hear what you
guys think what is your least favorite
Tom Hanks movie and/or performance who
do you want me to cover next on the show
leave a comment and let me know follow
me on twitter at awesome underscore
walter and come back next week for a
brand new top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
by hydrated game have you seen Thomas
st. and volunteer whereas a hello job
isn't that the film where it plays a
rich man who joins up hi gentium have
you seen Thomas aches and Valentina
what is the hello job isn't that the
film where he plays a rich man who
unruly joins a Peace Corps but it's
caught he joins the army no but another
fool replays a rich man one woman he
joins the Peace Corps but of course he
burns but of course he ventures
somewhere in the orient and there should
be a better man